let's self X equal negative 30 so okay
let's have a look maybe we will
encounter this problem when we have a
guide this obviously everything is going
to be the same except that's going to be
negative 3 which means that we negative
a quarter- corridor a lot it's a job
okay so i think we will so when we get
to t equals 12 on pi sine inverse of
negative a corner you can already see
this is going to give you a negative
answer right because sine inverse has
what kind of symmetry is a function is
mod symmetry so if i put in a positive
here in fact this should give me exactly
the negative of this right so i'm just
going to go straight to the
approximately okay but that doesn't make
sense right i'm looking for the first
time I don't want it I don't want to do
any doctor who business and go back in
time so what will I do with this number
how do I get from that let me draw the
ground little bit bigger and maybe you
want two minutes to convey out only a
rough sketch before and try and work out
what on earth do this number okay so
what we have found is like what's the
number that it's providing us it's over
here
yeah that make sense okay so how is it
that I get from that number to a time
that's positive that makes sense over
here what do I do so can we just how do
i use the first part because because
it's the sine function is periodic which
means that the first time it crosses
negative then it's the same as the first
time it crosses it crosses paws of
dating in the first half of the space so
about the first section first then is
the same as the first step on that side
you lost me a little bit where are you
talking about so we're talking so you
know the sine function is like it's like
a bit yeah yeah so you're talking about
the fact that its reflection yet okay
just pause for a second the reason why
this is hard is because you are not
using the language of the question right
so we could say to the left to the right
ok so here we're wiped out it took that
amount of time to travel to the right 30
meters yes no reason so therefore you
can say that same amount of time walk it
travels to the left that amount of time
from here right does that make sense
because of the symmetry of motion in
fact we kind of did do that because you
can see we've got the same number up
okay so have a look have a look now I
want you to go forward in time until I'm
dead what what time is that by the way
that's 12 seconds per second you can see
the distance I now need to go further
forward in time is this distance which
by the symmetry of this function is
exactly that same distance right it's
the same since I found up here as well
they're all the same distance or same
time this distance this distance this
disease yeah okay so therefore if I have
to move forward this amount which is
10.9 652 da da da right then the time it
takes me to come around all the way is
time equals 12 plus point 9 6 52 mm
that make sense okay now I should point
out that point weren't expecting a guy
takes five to that was four significant
figures from here but this is not for
securities anymore is it what is it this
is six so I should approximate further
is out the answer ok so again was that
hard numerically Norwich if the concept
was challenging to wrap your head around
what's going on how do i use the
symmetry of this function to get a time
which doesn't make sense does it make
sense to a time that does so see what we
see what a bummer does anyone ask any
clarifying questions there because I
feel like that was confusing require
finding particular points my then we'll
pass this question ya see so full party
of the first method that you went down
yep um so you just plus 20 if i add 24
to this i will get a time when i am
there but i won't get the first time we
get the first time so have a look
geometrically or what happens if i add
24 seconds he's the answer that
calculator headed me right and 24
seconds is one whole period right so
therefore i go 24 seconds all the way to
over here right so yes i am at x equals
negative 30 and 30 mins to the left ok
but it's the second time i get there not
the first yeah so not quite so I say
okay what's what is this distance what
is this distance sorry i should say what
is this time ok and the size of the time
is that many seconds yeah and i can see
geometrically because my graph is decent
or your grandma perfect ever but that
distance and this distance are the same
right it'll take me the same time to go
30 meters away from the origin whichever
direction I go in ok so therefore I take
that same
and I add it was 12 so you notice that's
not this plus 12 you notice that yeah
because then that would be 12 minus will
be going the other way yeah if I did if
I added 12 to this where would I be on
the graph where would I be the primary
water 30 very good I would be at the
second time I'm 30 meters to the right
because look if I put in twelve minus
that right there's 12 minus that see
I've gone to backwards in time right
which is here the second time of those
events yes correct so it's really 12 +
this sense